that's how this is supposed to work and  it's important for us to all be patient  when wild votes are are being counted  this is how it's supposed to work if  this is how it's supposed to work then  how come for pretty much every election  in all of American history since the  founding of our country until two years  ago how come that's not how it worked  how come that's only how it works now  as of as of 2020.  if that's how it's supposed to work  well because we need to make sure that  we tally every single mail-in vote  okay  why do we have so many mail-in votes  well  because of covid  because of what Cove is over it's been  over for years  well  because  we want to cheat that's why that's why  that's why they're doing it